that's it I'm calling an emergency
meeting on toy animation you're not
getting away with this you thought you
were so smooth so clever creating one of
the most incredible Feats of Animation
in the history of weekly anime but I
knew the truth I knew it was all to hide
this one little thing
oh it's a coincidence you say there's no
way any toei animator would purposely
animate and among us into the episode
for lows then what about this
but all of this silly evidence is
actually unnecessary because I present
to you the most damning evidence of all
the animator himself acknowledged the
Among Us on Twitter I mean what an
absolute Legend